letzte woche haben wir euch bei youtube
gefragt welches thema der deutschen
aussprache ihr am schwierigsten findet
über 6000 leute haben an dieser umfrage
teilgenommen
die meisten von euch haben gesagt dass
sie das deutsche r am schwierigsten
finden
hierüber haben wir schon einmal ein
video gemacht was ihr hier findet jeder
fünfte von euch hat gesagt dass er ein
problem hat mit deutschen vokalen und
zwar speziell mit kurzen und langen
vokalen und genau darüber wollen wir
heute reden je nachdem woher er kommt
und was eure muttersprache ist wird es
euch einfacher oder leichter fallen die
deutschen vokale zu lernen
englische muttersprachler zum beispiel
sind daran gewohnt dass manche lokale
kurz und manche lokale lang gesprochen
werden zum beispiel du dann go go für
englische muttersprachler ist es daher
einfacher sich auch in anderen sprachen
darauf einzustellen
polen hingegen zum beispiel kennen gar
keine unterschiede in der länge von
vokalen die vokale im polnischen werden
immer gleich lang ausgesprochen und
deswegen haben es auch polen schwerer
die aussprache im deutschen und speziell
die aussprache von vokabeln zu lernen
janosch hat das persönlich sehr
frustriert als er deutsch gelernt hat
und er hat mir gesagt dass er nie einen
lehrer getroffen hat der das richtig
adressiert hat oder mit ihm oder anderen
deutsch lernen geübt hat woran erkennt
man also im deutschen ob ein vokal kurz
oder lang gesprochen wird
ganz so einfach ist es im deutschen
leider nicht herauszufinden wie ein wort
oder ein lokal ausgesprochen wird denn
man kann an der schreibweise nicht immer
erkennen wie ein vokal ausgesprochen
wird hier ein beispiel der weg und weg
weg und weg diese beiden worte werden
gleich geschrieben
aber unterschiedlich ausgesprochen
genauso wie nach und nach hat ein langes
haar hat ein kurzes aber beide silben
enden gleich mit ch das deutsche wort
zum beispiel gehweg bedeutet im
englischen sightwalk aber wenn ich sage
gehweg dann heißt das go away
die aussprache von einigen worten muss
man daher leider individuell lernen aber
es gibt auch regeln die einem helfen zu
erkennen ob ein vokal kurz oder lang
gesprochen wird und diese regeln stellen
wir euch jetzt vor
als erstes beginnen wir mit den langen
lokalen ein hinweis darauf dass ein
vokal lang gesprochen wird ist zum
beispiel der doppel vokal wie in dem
wort staat see oder most immer wenn ihr
einen doppel vokal sät wird der vokal
lang gesprochen
eine zweite möglichkeit ist dass
dehnungs haar wenn man an einen vokal
ein haar an hängt dann bedeutet das auch
dass der vokal lang gesprochen wird
zum beispiel lohn huhn hahn diese worte
haben alle einen langen vokal aber auch
ein e nach einem kann dafür sorgen dass
anni lang gesprochen wird zb in die
liebe der dieb oder das sieht immer wenn
ein e auf eine folgt macht es dass sie
länger nicht zu verwechseln mit
das wird nämlich wie gesprochen ein
anderer buchstabe der manchmal noch
einen einfluss hat ist das wenn ein eher
nach einem a steht oder nach einem e
dann wird das fast auch wie ein langes
angesprochen
zum beispiel der stadt klingt sehr
ähnlich wie der staat es klingt
eigentlich fast genau gleich oder der
lehrer klingt genauso wie ein langes am
ende
lehrer kommen wir zu den kurzen vokalen
ihr könnt euch merken dass ihr immer
einen kurzen lokal sprecht wenn ihr
einen doppelten konsonanten seht zum
beispiel in wollen der wille der fluss
der finne
das sind alles doppel konsonanten und
vor einem doppel konsonant steht immer
ein kurzer vokalen es gibt auch
konsonanten kombinationen die genauso
wie ein doppel konsonant sind zum
beispiel die theorie in die stadt ca wie
in der bäcker oder backen oder auch tz
wie in katze oder sitzen auch vor diesen
kombinationen stehen immer kurze vokale
jetzt vergleichen wir noch mal kurze und
lange vokale damit ihr den direkten
unterschied hört wir fangen an mit a
kurz die stadt lang der start der stahl-
oder auch stark wir gehen weiter mit
kurz ist zum beispiel stellen oder die
stille lang ist die stele stellen stelle
stehle
der stil der stil und still und
interessant ist auch dass manche wörter
unterschiedlich geschrieben werden zum
beispiel der stil und der stil und
trotzdem gleich ausgesprochen werden
ein wort mit dem jahr ist immer noch
probleme hat ist die höhle
das ebit gelang ausgesprochen im
vergleich zu die hölle und dort wird das
öl kurz ausgesprochen
das kannst du würde sagen könnte sagen
geht zur hölle das klingt für mich genau
gleich als wenn du diesen unterschied
nicht machen kann dass höhle hölle hölle
hölle hölle hölle hölle ja fast es ist
gar nicht so einfach für janisch und
wahrscheinlich auch für andere polnische
muttersprachler diesen unterschied zu
hören und dann auch zu sprechen
zwischen den kurzen und langen lokalen
ein typischer fehler auch ist zb der
unterschied zwischen polen und polen ja
zb es gibt zu viele pollen um mich herum
richtig ausgesprochen
es gibt so viele polen um die führung
das sollte man besser nicht sein
kommen wir zum einen der lange vocalist
zum beispiel in polen oder pol was ein
bekannter nachname ist in deutschland
der kurze vocalist in polen oder in
polster dass das hat einen kurzen vokal
wie in bus oder busse ein langer vokal
wäre wie im flug oder buße auch ganz
interessant dieses sz was ein besonderer
deutsche konsument ist deutet in
deutschen immer an dass es sich um einen
langen vokal davor handelt also vor
einem sz steht auch immer ein langer
vokal gruß fuß genau solche wörter und
noch zwei weitere beispiele aus den
umlauten und mit den umlauten ist
immer ein bisschen schwieriger zu
sprechen wie wir gerade schon gehört
haben hätte kurzes elf meter langes
hätte nähte oder zum beispiel das wort
hütte im vergleich zu hüte hüte ist ein
langes hütte ist ein kurzes hüte hüte
wenn ihr jetzt eure aussprache weiter
üben möchte dann kann ich euch empfehlen
dass ihr mal unsere app sie länger
ausprobiert denn in zeeland kommt es vor
allem darauf an seine eigene aussprache
zu hören und zu trainieren
auf see längsee tier videos in kurzen
sätzen und nachdem ihr einsatzort könnt
ihr selber eure eigene aussprache
aufnehmen und dann mit der original
aussprache vergleichen
diese weise hilft euch dabei eure eigene
aussprache zu analysieren und
schließlich auch zu verbessern
guckt euch die seite mal an es gibt dort
viele inhalte umsonst und wenn euch die
seite gefällt könnt ihr sogar ein
mitglied werden und später noch mehr
inhalte freischalten
da freuen wir uns sehr wenn ihr das mal
ausprobiert und uns auch feedback dazu
gibt das was für diese woche tschüss und
wir sehen uns am sonntag wieder
[Musik]
1 2 3 4 5